I have a question.
[Arabic recitation]
of the modern state of Israel?
Who's it named after?
Ben-Gurion. Do you know why he's
considered the one
that is the founder of the state of
Israel even though on paper
he's not.
He is revered as the founder of the
state of Israel. Do you know why?
Because he revived the Hebrew language.
He unified the otherwise entirely
disjointed
Zionist movement
by unifying their language.
The airport's named after him.
An interesting quote from this man.
Kind of a peek into the mind
set.
You know, he was asked
all these Arabs around you and all these
Muslimin around you
aren't you afraid
being this little tiny state in the
middle of all these hostile, allegedly
hostile,
states around you and countries around
you?
Don't you fear the Muslimin?
You know what he said?
Yeah,
what she had to say to them in
sometimes,
you know, wisdom comes from all
different angles.
He said, "We will start to fear the
Muslims when we see their message fill
up for salatul Fajr."
When we see their message fill up for
salatul Fajr. What's interesting is that
when I was growing up in Palestine,
in
the otherwise we were supposed to be my
area was supposed to be under Jordanian
government rule.
And we were what were referred to as
Fatah. And this is before the official
state of the PLO, right?
they used to have
military jeeps camped out in the dead of
dark in the middle of the desert waiting
to catch people going to salatul Fajr.
And I remember many a times
having to either turn around and go back
home
or to literally hide in the trees
from
military convoys to not pick us up
because we were on our way headed to
salatul Fajr.
And there were actual spies
that were paid for, planted in the
masjid, their only job was to take down
names
of young men that come to salat al-fajr.
Now,
you've got a little voice in the back of
your mind, especially the
young younger Americans amongst us,
saying, "Oh, you know, is that proven?
That's a conspiracy."
You know, it's interesting about
conspiracies
is the state of Palestine is slowly
being
disintegrated and melted, and the state
of Israel is slowly being ballooned, and
we are actually categorized
as a country
that
is not officially recognized by the
United Nations, which is the state of
Palestine. Now, this only happened in
the about 10 or less,
you know, couple decades at most,
where it is considered to be a
non-state. How did this happen?
How did this happen? Was there a
conspiracy, or was this just organic?
Is just naturally the an entire country
faded into obscurity? Does that happen?
So,
the issue here is what why is this
important to us?
Some of us who lived in such a place,
and I know also other
Arab countries this, and maybe even
non-Arab countries, but Muslim
countries.
Libya is a very good example. Syria is a
very good example.
Where salat al-fajr, salah in the
masajid, especially during certain
places, during certain times, is
absolutely off limits. As a matter of
fact, your father and your mother will
fight with you tooth and nail
to try to stop their young sons from
going to Salat al-Fajr and going to the
masjid in general
because they don't want any trouble with
the government.
maybe the old-timers here can remember
that. You remember this Abu Usama?
Abu Musab, you remember these days? I
don't know if it's still that
Syria, you remember these days?
I remember being picked up by military
jeeps, convoys in the dead of night.
There is There are few things more
haunting
to a young Palestinian boy
than the silhouette
of an Israeli military jeep. It used to
strike
dark, black dread and terror into our
hearts in a way that I can't even
describe to you.
I remember many of times being picked up
either on our way to salah, at the
masjid, on our way to Fajr in the dead
of night. They just pop out of nowhere
and getting slapped around and kicked
around and sent home and then later
having to report to
Israeli
internal, it's kind of the
FBI of
or MI5 of Israel.
And you know, what were you doing at
Fajr? What are you doing going to the
masjid? You know, are you some kind of
terrorist? Are you an extremist?
Why is your beard growing out a little
bit, right? Et cetera. You remember in
Egypt
in the late 50s, early 60s, in the fall
of
in the fall of Al-Malik Farouk, the king
of the last king of Egypt, Farouk, and
who took his place? Do you guys
remember?
Gamal Abdel Nasser.
Gamal Abdel Nasser was propped it up
by Al-Ikhwan Al-Muslimeen. And at that
time, Al-Ikhwan Al-Muslimeen was 90%
Islamic driven, 10%
politics and policies. Now, you could
say it's probably exactly the opposite,
but at that time
he, as soon as he got into power, he
turned on all of them. And he started to
collect them from the masajid
salat al-fajr, salat al-zuhr, salat
al-isha, in the masajid. Started
collecting them and putting them in
prisons that nobody would ever hear from
them again, or not hear for them from
them for decades. Same thing happened in
Libya. The same thing happened recently
in Bangladesh.
actually, hundreds, if not thousands of
scholars were executed in Bangladesh
just of recent. Sudan,
Syria, and so forth. What's the point
of all this?
The point of all this is that we live in
a country right now
where we have liberties
that maybe are not allotted to us in our
own Muslim countries.
Look at these big, beautiful doors right
here.
Just open.
You can get in your car and come make
salat al-fajr
and your name's not going to be on a
list
and you're not going to be in
and you're not worried about the
boogeyman. You remember in those
in those days in under the reign of
Gamal Abdel Nasser, and then after him
as-Sadat, and then after him
Mubarak,
you'll notice that
99% of the scholars of that era, none of
them had beards.
You notice that?
the most was al-Husary, and he was
considered to be a very
strong-willed man, with a little tiny
short beard. That's not because they
didn't love the sunnah or didn't love
following the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam. It was because these things
were illegal.
Right? We grew up in those times.
This masjid is only going to be as good
as its attendees.
We cannot sit and accept the status quo.
We need to work individually and
together
to fill this masjid up. I want it to be
busting at the seams, not just for
salah, but especially for salatul fajr.
Especially those of us who have young
men at home.
High school age, middle school age, get
your bones out of that bed and get in
the car, we're going to salatul fajr.
The Arabs have a proverb, "Man shabba
ala shayin
shaba alayh."
Whoever grows up in his adolescence on a
particular habit
will usually grow old on those habits.
And when you instill that in your child,
especially men,
especially young men,
they will be lost if they don't have,
starting with the masjid, starting with
salat al-fajr,
they're coming to the masjid.
We need to see
young men vibrant in the masjid, the
rest of the prayers,
and this is something that we have to
work on individually and together.
You guys are already here for fajr.
So, what's the point of me telling you
this?
Right? You're already here. No, you have
a neighbor, you have a son, you have a
cousin, you have a brother.
Especially young men, get up, let's go
to fajr. And I know we can do it. I know
as parents we can do it. You know why?
Because we dedicate our children to 12
years of continuous schooling where they
get up at a certain time,
dress a certain way, do certain
assignments, get certain grades, come
home at a certain time, and we respect
that so much that we actually build our
lives around the schooling
schedule. Isn't that true? Our whole
life is shaped by the schedule of the
school.
We don't ever call the school and say,
"Oh, so-and-so is not going to be in
today. My son's not coming. He was too
tired."
You know, he was tired last night, so I
just thought, "Eh,
nix on that. Let him sleep in." Or he'll
just come to He'll come to school
whenever he comes. He comes a little
hour or two late. We don't do that.
We get him up out of the bed with a
whip. Correct?
Only when we have this kind of
discipline
with our deen, are we going to
, advance. And so,
, the thing is is that a lot of us as
parents, even I, suffer from this as
well.
You almost are afraid
to
that you're going to be too
tough on your child.
You're afraid that
if I'm too
, strict with my son to get up and go
to Fajr or if I, you know, push him too
much, he's going to resent me.
This is waswas of shaytan.
No child will ever grow
past his adolescence
and
complain that his father and mother were
not
,
you know, disciplined enough with him.
As long as what you do is not random
and there are clear rules, and if you
break the rules, there are clear
consequences, but you're not driven by
emotion, but you're driven by
objectivity, they will always respect
you and pray for you after that. Even if
they go through a spell of resentment,
that's okay. They'll come back and
they'll say,
"Alhamdulillah.
Maybe my dad didn't teach me much, but
one thing he taught me was every day
we went to make Salat al-Fajr. It was
breathing. It was eating
breakfast.
You remember during Ramadan how full the
masjid was for Fajr?
There's no reason we can't do that
every day. So,
,
there this reminds me of a quick story
I'll share with you
about Umar ibn Abdil Aziz. Do we know
Umar ibn Abdil Aziz?
Umar ibn Abdil Aziz is considered to be
the fifth
of the four Khulafa.
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
mentioned
that the Khilafa
the successorship of prophethood after
his death would be how many years?
Huh?
30. 30 years.
And then after that it would turn into
what?
Kingship. It would be kings.
But the Khalifa of Muhammad Rasulillah
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam would be 30
years. And that ended exactly
with
the
succession of
al-Hasan radiAllahu anhu al-Hasan ibn
Ali ibn Abi Talib. Roughly 6 months
after the death of Ali ibn Abi Talib or
the martyrdom of Ali ibn Abi Talib.
But because he was such
a revivalist, because he brought
such light to a dark world at the
time, and because there were so many
prophecies that he ended up fulfilling
in just 2 years as the Khalifa.
He is considered to be the fifth of the
four Khulafa.
Even though there is a huge gap between
him and
the the companions Khilafa.
So, we hear about Omar ibn Abdul Aziz.
He was never corrupted by wealth.
He was a major scholar of Islam. We're
not talking about
he was a leader, but he dabbled in
Islamic sciences. He is considered one
of the top finest upper echelon of
scholarship
of his entire era, right?
And of the entirety of Islam.
So, this is a great man. What kind of
childhood did he have?
There's
a good
story that kind of captures
the effects that his father had on
raising such a man.
He was actually sent by his father's
father His father was a prince. They
were royalty. They weren't just regular
people, right? They were royalty.
And so, he sent Omar bin Abdul Aziz
to
Al-Asma'i to mentor him as a young boy.
Meaning that he would be in that city.
Al-Asma'i is a major scholar of Hadith,
Fiqh, and Lughah.
Linguistics.
He was a impressive linguist. And so,
they would send their children to reside
under the mentorship of scholars in
their adolescent years to be able to
learn more than just knowledge, to learn
character, to learn
discipline, etc. So, basically, what his
job was was to service his sheikh.
Carry his shoes. A prince carrying the
shoes of a scholar, yes.
So, one day
Omar bin Abdul Aziz, he was about
probably
just after the age of puberty. He was
very young, probably between 10 and 12,
somewhere in there.
He missed
the first
of a salah in in jama'.
He didn't miss the first rak'.
He didn't miss the recitation.
He missed takbirat al-ihram. When the
[Arabic recitation]
row.
Al-Asma'i saw this
and immediately asked him, "Come here.
Why did you miss
takbirat al-ihram?
Why'd you miss the first takbir?"
He said
that
one of the servants
was he had just bathed and she was
braiding his hair for him.
And if he had left at that exact moment
to make salah, his braids wouldn't have
been finished.
So, we're talking about a difference of
a minute or two, a few minutes.
So,
he said, "Okay."
Immediately sent a letter to his father.
"Your son,
Omar,
missed takbirat al-ihram on this day and
this salah." Does this sound a big
deal to you guys? To us, does this
sound a big deal?
If you spoke to the average Muslim child
today about missing takbirat al-ihram,
would they even understand what the heck
you're talking about?
So, what are you saying? I was here for
salah. What do you mean?
If you get here by tashahhud, the final
tashahhud is good enough.
Right? This is takbirat al-ihram. His
father wrote a letter back to his son,
"I vow not to speak to you until you
shave your head."
Now, some of us may say,
"That's extreme, right?
It's kind of extreme." Let me ask you a
question. What about if he was in
swimming club and he wanted to shave his
head so he could swim
a couple milliseconds faster cuz that's
what all the other students were doing.
They shaved their head in the swim team
and he was shaving his head to be on the
swim team. Do we view that as extreme?
Is that extremism?
No?
So the issue isn't really the shaving of
the head. The issue really is then
priorities, isn't it?
It's priorities. It's not really an
issue of extremism, is it?
Cuz we'll shave the head. If all the
kids in school had their heads shaved,
would we not shave our children's heads?
If the child got lice and couldn't go
back to school until the lice was gone,
would we not shave his head so he
doesn't miss school?
Yeah?
Okay. He's shaving his head because he's
not disciplined.
And he's missing salah and his father
said,
"Your hair is more important than your
salah? I'm not speaking to you until you
shave your head." And he did so as a
dutiful son.
Fast forward 20 years, we have Omar bin
Abdul Aziz.
Right? Now I'm not saying that that's
what we need to do now. That's That's
not the level that our children are at.
That's not the level that even our our
adults are at.
However,
we need to set priorities. The thing
that your child is most desperate for
is for you to teach them priorities.
Right? So let's work on filling this
masjid up, especially for fajr.
Everyone, you have a neighbor, you have
someone. Think of someone today
that you can humbug and bother until you
get them to come make salat al-fajr once
a week.
That's your mission.
Get that done
and then work on a second and a third.
Just one day a week, not every day. Just
one day a week. Come on Fajr, on Jummah,
on Saturday, on Sunday, make Salat
al-Fajr. Bother them until they avoid
your calls
about making Fajr.
I'm sure all of us have someone in mind.
This is how we start to rebuild
[Arabic recitation]